this is the Sanchez family with two of
their three sons the oldest boy has been
attending kindergarten for the past six
months
Alexis native tongue is Spanish now he
has to learn German
you better go convey this company okay I
see that with my other colleagues who
have come here from Mexico en el caso
there is their small children all
learned perfect German and kindergarten
I bring the owner Lila DiMeo perfect but
their son isn't in a very good mood
today
and the teacher knows why a lot of the
children are sick with colds at the
moment
Alexis mother likes the fact that
attention is paid to each child yeah
he's your buddy whether they play the
whole time here they're free here in
Mexico the little ones have to sit like
grown-ups it's certainly different here
if algo diferente for a suspect bad
homburg the new home is like something
from a picture book who goes Sanchez
cycles to work something that would not
be possible in many parts of Mexico he
worked for Fresenius back home he's an
accountant and he speaks English and
Spanish Fresenius makes medical devices
for hospitals manufacturing them in
factories around the world so the
company needs specialists like Sanchez
with the blue card he and his family can
live and work in Germany long term
Sanchez audits the business numbers from
all the global locations we visit the
subsidiary poor around two out two weeks
and during these two weeks we made a
review of the financing from
and how is the control how the security
how is a compliance of the company in
with the local rules six colleagues from
four different countries is normal at
Fresenius like all the accountants here
Sanchez has to be at least bilingual and
have the proper academic qualifications
he's an ideal candidate because he
learned about our business already being
in Mexico for a couple of years and he's
familiar with our products even he was
working in New Mexico we have production
sites so he he knows the product he
knows about our rules already so this is
the ideal situation if someone is
joining our team my first option is I
want to stay here for a long period of
time this is the first option even my
wife and I would talk about that and we
think that it's interesting to to have a
life here because we are so happy now
that Sanchez has the blue card he has to
learn German that's the next hurdle for
all immigrants there's the competition
about good and valuable employees that
doesn't matter from which country they
are coming and of course in Germany as
we know we have not the ongoing growth
of the population we won't find them
entirely in Germany and we need more
people coming outside from Germany
who go Sanchez gets help settling in
from his employer for instance the
company helped him submit documentation
to the immigration authorities the human
resources manager at Fresenius Martin
brew got him proof of yearly income blue
card applicants have to earn at least
forty eight thousand euros Brewer thinks
that's an unreasonably high amount and
says there's room for lots of other
improvements all inside our keeper we as
employers would benefit from less
bureaucracy meaning a simplification of
the forms simpler recognition of
academic qualifications for instance
would be very happy if we could submit
certificates in English English with
soit misaligned - Quentin HUBO Sanchez's
children are well on their way to
integrating into German life a bit of
Zumba in the afternoon gives them a
taste of German sporting clubs and who
go Sanchez and his wife are getting into
the spirit of things as well
Oh